エワンメーソタンエカンサマヤンバガワーサワッティヤンヴィーラティジェータワニーアナータピンディカッサラーメ
ある時 お釈迦様がジェータワナという林のアナータピンディカという孤児が作った精進に住んでおられたと
テーナコーパナサマエーナアリッタッサナーマビクノウガッダバーディプッダッセエーワルーパンパーパカンディッティガタンウッパンナンホーティ
その時なんですね アリッタという名前のガッダバーディプッダッセ
ガッダバーディっていうのは
高階 高尚の人なんですけど
その名前はアリッタなんですね
彼に あの 今出家しているんです
今出家しているんですけど
このように この不善な考え方
不善な悪い考え方が生まれたんですね
どのような悪い考え方かというと
タタ
ーハンバガワタダンマンデーシタンアージャナーミヤターイエーメーアンタラーイカーダンマウッタバガワターテーパティセワトーナーランアンテラーヤーヤーティ
彼が考えたこの不善なことは
この こういうことなんですね
お釈迦様が危険なものだと
邪魔なものだとおっしゃったいくつかの教えがありますと
で お釈迦様がいくつかの事柄をね
大変心を清らかにする人にとっては邪魔なものだと
危険なものだとおっしゃったんですよ
で この人が あ そういうことをしたっても
別にそんな邪魔になるわけじゃないんだと
危険になるわけじゃないんだと
というふうな考え方を起こしたんですね
そういう考え方が起きたんですね
アッソースンコーサンバフラービク
そうするともう比丘たちがその話を
もう彼の話を聞いたんですね
アリッタッサキラナーマビクノウガッダバーディプッダッセエーワルーパンパーパカンディッティガタンウッパンナン
比丘たちには話が行きました
このアリッタさんにこんな悪い
不善なる考え方が起きたんだぞと
その不善なる考え方もそちらに次にまた回目も言ってるんですね
どういう考え方かというと
心成長するためには障害になる事柄が
別にそんなことをしたっても
まぁ邪魔にはなりません
大丈夫やと お釈迦様はそういうふうにおっしゃったんだけど
それはそんなに危険なものではないという考え方
それで
アタコーテービクイエナアリットービクウガッダバーディプッドーテーヌプサンカメンツプサンカメントーアリッタンガッダバーディビクンアリッタンビクンガッダバーディプッダンエータダボーチョン
その時 その比丘たちがアリッタさんのところに行って
こういうふうに言ったんですね
サッチャンキルテヤウソアリットーエーワルーパンパーパカンディッティガタンウッパンナン
彼に聞くんですよ あなたにはそのような
本当ですか？と こんな不善な悪の思考
パーパカンというのは悪ということですからね
悪的な意見ですね 邪見ですね
パーパカンディッティガタン
ディッティガタンで何か意見に入り込んじゃって
それをずっとしがみついていることで
あなたにすごい悪の思考ね
生まれたっていうことは本当でしょうかと
そこで彼がエワンビャコーアハンアウソバガワうんうんと言うんですね
まあ私はまあそう思いますよと
このお釈迦様は悪いと思った思考がそんなに悪いと私は思いませんと
次にアタコーテービクワアリッタンビクンガッダバーディプッダンエータスマーパーパカーディッティガターヴィヴェーチェートゥカーマー
そこで比丘たちが そのアリッタさん比丘を
そのパーパカーディッティガター
不善な悪思考から悪意見から
あの ヴィヴェーチェートゥカーマー
離れてもらいたく サマヌユンジャンティ
まあいろいろもう比較して合わせて説得させようとするんですね
話し合うっていうことですね
サマヌガーハンティ おなじみなんですね
まあいろんなこの質問出したりする
あんた これはどう思います？これはどう思いますか？そう言ったってのはこうではないかとか
そうやってこの質問出したりする
サマヌユンジャンティっていうのは
普通比較して教えてあげること
サマヌバーサンティ で
二人とも同じ意見を持ってるところをまた持ってきて
その こういう点でこういう点であなたも私たちも同じ意見でしょうと
その意見に基づいて またですから
そういうことになるんではないかと
そういうふうにこのダイアログというか
会話を持っていくんですね
ですから この人と違う意見を持ってる人と話す場合は
だいたいそういうつの方法でやってはいたそうですね
今嫌われる方法ですけど
サマヌンジャンティっていうのは
まあまあ いろいろ比較して例えを出したりして話すことなんです
注釈書ではキンラッヒコートンラッディンワデーヒティプッチマナサマヌンジャンティということで
相手の意見をまず聞いて
その意見はなぜその意見に至ったんでしょうかとか
理由は言ってくださいと
それできちんとこの相手の発表をちゃんと聞いてもらう
サマヌンジャンティっていうのは
まあ相手と話し合って
相手の意見をすごくこの聞いてもらって
そこはこういうことでしょうとまず確定しておくこと
それで相手方がこういうわけで
こういう理屈で こういう論理で
私はこういうことを言いますよと
ですから 相手がちゃんと自分の意見を思い存分出して
それはまあ理屈もつけてきちっと話してもらうという立場なんですよ
ダイアログの方法ですけど
ダイレクトの場合も 一人がまず自分の意見をちゃんと言わなくちゃいかんでしょうに
例えば学会などで発表するでしょうに
まず研究者が自分の意見をまず発表する
その場合は 自分がどういうわけでこの意見出しましたかっていうことはちゃんと証明しなくちゃいけないんですね
その最初の段階なんですね
サマヌンジャンティっていうのは
まあ別にまあどういったところではないんですけど
ただ話し合ったって意味だけでは十分ですけどもね
まあそこら辺はまあ置いておきましょう
あまり難しいしね ただ話し合いましたと
マーエワンアウスワリッタワチェ
それで比丘たちの言葉はマーエワンアウスワリッタワチェ
このようなことは言ってはいけませんと
マーバガワンタンアッバーチッキ
お釈迦様を誹謗してはいけないと
アビアーチッキっていうのは誹謗という意味なんですが
アーチッキっていうのは何か発表すること
喋ることをですね アビっていうのは人が言ったことにも上に
まあそれもうその上の何かを言うというふうな意味なんですね
ですから それはやっぱり誹謗って意味になるんです
ネヒサードゥバガトアッバーチッカナ
お釈迦様を誹謗することは良くないんだよと
ネヒバガワーエワンワデイヤ
お釈迦様はそんなことは教えませんと
アネーカパリヤーエナヒアウスワリッタアンタラーイカダンマウッタバガワタ
お釈迦様がこの障害になるんだよという方は
アネーカパリヤーエナ
ありとあらゆる方法で教えたんではないかと
アランチャパナテパティセワントアンタラーヤ
そこでお釈迦様 結論は
その事柄を実践すると
実行すると 必ずしも危険に堕落しちゃうという
ある障害になるんだよと
お釈迦様がいろんな方法で教えたんではないかと
それからお釈迦様がいろんな方法で教えたということは
アネーカパリアエーナ
パリアーヤっていうのは言葉変えて変えて言うことなんです
何か一つ喋る場合は まあ一つの方法で喋る
それから言葉変えてまた喋る
それはアネーカパリアーヤと言うんですね
また言葉を変えてまた話す
だから同じポイントをいろいろ言葉変えて喋ることをアネーカパリアーヤと言うんですね
だから言葉を変えるということは
たとえを変える あるいは単純に言葉だけ変えるとかね
言い方を変えるとかいろいろあります
変え方 それでお釈迦様がどんないう風に変えて教えたんですかというところは次にくるんですね
アッパッサーダーカーマーブッター・バガヴァター・バフドゥッカー・バフウーパヤーサー
アーディーナヴォ・エッタ・ビーヨ
で カーマー カーマーっていうのは欲のことですね
欲がアッパッサーダー
アッサーダーっていうのは楽しむとこなんですね
欲の楽しみがアッパ 少々ですよと
喜びですね 欲によって得られる喜びがほんの少々ですよと
わずかですよと ウッター・バガヴァター
バフドゥッカー 苦しみの方が多いよと
多いと バフウーパヤーサー
ウパヤーサーっていうのは悩むことなんですね
で 心で悩むこと ドゥッカといえば体の苦しみも入りますけど
ウパヤースでは精神的な悩みですね
それで悩みもものすごい多いんだよと
それで欲は楽しいものなんですよ
楽しいものなんですけど
ほんのちょっとしか楽しいことがない
苦しみの方がすごい多いと
で 悩みの方がものすごく多いんだと
それでアーディーナヴォ・エッタ・ビーヨ
アーディーナヴォっていうのはデメリットのこと
悪い結果が出るものはアーディーナヴォと言うんですね
良い結果が出るものにはアーニサンサと言うんですね
で ここでカーマの欲の場合は
あのデメリットの方がビーヨ
ものすごいたくさんですよと
そこでそれはお釈迦様が言い方変えて変えて言うんですね
一番目はアッティ・サンカ・ルーペマ・カーマ・ブッタ・バガヴァタ
で 欲っていうのはあのコッサのようにと骨の鎖と書いてますけどね
アッティ・サンカリカンっていうのは
この まあ骨 コッサっていう言葉はあまりわかりませんですけど
まあ骸骨でしょうか で
欲は骨のようなものですよと
一番目の例え で 骨っていうのはそんなにすごい美味しいものでもないしね
食べる骨であろうとも
まあ食べ物で考えれば
もう全く肉なんかはついてない骨ばっかしだったら
もう食べるもの何もない
で 時々人間の目で見てね
犬ってなんであんな骨が好きがるんでしょうかとかね
まあそれはまあ人間の考え方で
まあ犬は骨を好きなんですね
それは別な話で 犬には骨消化できるし
まあ食べることもできますけど
でも人間から見れば なんでこんなバカなことをやってるんだよ
肉はついてないんではないかと
で 人間が骨食べてみたっても
もうただ噛んで疲れるだけで
何も体にお腹に入るものではないんですね
で それはその場合は大体この
まあ仏教の世界では 出家の世界では
体っていうのはただ骸骨でしょうと
骨だよと で そういうふうに場合は人骨なんですね
その時はあまり気持ちいいものではなくなっちゃうんですね
で またこの なんでこの注釈層にその例えの説明が出てこないかっていう
ここら辺に出てくるはずなんですけど
浄土論で書いたんだから書いてないかな
あるいは参照ぐらいでも書く必要ありますけど
で 二番目の例えは マンサピーシー
で 肉片 もろもろの欲は肉片のようだと
作戦に述べられている
言われてるんだと 肉片
肉片っていうのは肉の塊ということで
多くのものに骨をするという意味によってと
それはちょっと分かりにくいんですけど
これ別な意味がありますけど
まあ注釈層ではバフサーダーラ・ナッターナ
うーん まあそこちょっと分かりにくい例えなんです
違う解釈もありますけどね
まあ一応欲は まあ肉の
ちょっと肉の塊 塊 肉片のようなものだよと
で そこで考えているのは
どこ見たってのは肉ではないかと
例えば人間の体の一部肉を取ってみたっても
牛の体から一部取ってみたても
ただの肉なんですね で
見た限りはね 別にもう実験室に持って行って試してみれば
どんな肉かわかるんだけどね
そこまでする必要はないんですけど
で 肉だけで見るとそんな区別はできませんっていうことで
だから理由は出てこないんですね
楽しみが少々で苦しみが多いという理由は出てこないんですね
それでも お釈迦様の理屈は
欲が楽しみがほんのちょっとで苦しみが多い
デメリットの方が多いと
肉品と言えば それ出てこないんです
だからお釈迦様はどういう意味でそれを使ったかということはね
ちょっとこちらで説明してないんですよ
バフサアダハラナットという意味は
ちょっとみんなにこう勧めているという意味ではね
まあどうかなと思いますけど
一応私がまあ覚えているところなんですけど
まあそれはまあどうか定かどうかわかりませんだけど
他のところでまあわかりやすく書いてるとこあるんですね
あの それもまたこのワシですね
一羽のワシが 例えば肉のちょっと塊を持って飛んで持って空に飛ぶと
そうすると他のワシたちがそこにずっと群がって
互いにぎゅうぎゅうとケンカしたり
ものすごいすごくケンカするんで
ワシはくちばしでケンカしないんだからね
足でですからね かなりきついんです
で 怪我して死んじゃうんですね
ワシがこれ私が取ったものだから絶対あげませんよとしがみついていたら
そのワシが死んでしまっちゃうんですね
で 他のワシが足で蹴ったら
もうものすごい鋭いんだから
もの怪我するんですよ
だから自分の命が欲しければ
あの肉を捨てて逃げるしかない
肉を捨てた途端 他のワシがそれパクッと取っちゃいますから
それそのワシにやられちゃうんですね
で そういう風にみんなに危険ばっかしであって
まあやがてもう誰かがそれ食べたかもしれませんだけど
食べたワシもやっぱりもう傷だらけで
まあそこまで傷つけ怪我して
こんな肉一部を食べるべきかと
そのことはこの動物の世界でもものすごくあるんですね
ものすごい喧嘩するんだから
だから牙を出して相手を噛んだりしてね
あげなかったら だいたい動物は逃げちゃうんですね
凶暴な動物は 同じ仲間が出てきて
もう喧嘩をするから すぐ逃げちゃう
いくらお腹が空いても
飢えている状態であろうとも
やっぱりこれ欲を出しちゃうと私が死んじゃいますよと
で 逃げちゃうんです 逃げなかったら死ぬことにはもう決まってるんで
死ぬか死ぬほど苦しみを味わうかという
それはもう猿の世界でもあるし
お腹が空いてたまらなくて
まあそれで餌にすぐ手を出したならばね
まあランクの下位猿なんかはね
それでも上の猿たちがもう徹底的に攻めちゃうんですね
で 攻めて攻めて もう怪我させて
もう怪我したらもう三ヶ月間ぐらいそれ治らなくなっちゃうし
もう木を登れなくなっちゃうしね
大変苦しいんですよ だから手を出して取って食べたならば
それはもう美味しいことは確かなんですけど
そんなことをしたらどれぐらい危険が出てくるんでしょうかと
だから そのたとえから肉遍のたとえ出しているという意味なんですね
次のたとえはティノックーペマー
ティノックーペマーカーマーったたかた肉遍の次はい
松明のことですね 草で作った松明
草で松明作るとどうなるかというと
これは夜暗いんだから
どこかに行きたい時は松明作って
それを火をつけて持っていくんですよ
草の場合はもういきなりサラサラと燃えてしまっちゃうんですね
何一つ物のから全部燃えちゃうんですよ
で それで燃えるだけじゃなくて
全部もう手で持ってるでしょうに
全部が飛んじゃうし 自分の手に入ってきて手が焼けちゃうし
で 光当たってみるっていうことはなかなか大変なんです
光当たってみようと思っちゃったら
自分が火傷をするしか方法ないんですね
そうでなくて こうやって遠いところにそういう風に持つしか方法ないんですね
そうしたっても もうついもうもう草花
火花が飛んでくる可能性あります
あまりにも柔らかくて
ものすごい燃えやすいんですね
だからこの松明作る場合は
この松明に使う薪はそれなりにあるんですよ
草では誰も松明をあまり作れません
作るならば それなりの何か焚きっていうか
何か火をつけたいとかね
早く燃やしてほしいとかね
例えば薪いっぱい積み重ねてところで
それを早く火をつけたいので
その場合は草で作ったものを入れて
それに火をつけて それに刺しちゃうんですよ
そうすると燃えちゃいますね
それから昔 火を作った場合は
この何て言いますか あれ
あの木を削って削って火を作るでしょ
こうしたら穴があって
穴の中にこの木の棒一つ入れて
それをずっと手でか あるいは機械で回しちゃうと
そこからちょっと火の玉が出てくるんですね
そちらに綿のような何か柔らかいものをつけておくんですよ
そうするとそれに火をつけて
それで火の玉が出てくるんですね
それぐらい柔らかいものなんですね
干した草っていうのは
だからそれで松明は作れません
もうすぐもう燃えてしまいますからね
だから松明のたとえというのは
もう確かに明かりは出してくれるんだけど
結局は役に立ちませんということで
自分が火傷をすることで終わるかもしれません
松明に使うならばね 次のたとえはアンガーラカース
よくは炭火口ですか 炭火
まあ穴ということですけど
一応炭で炭を何か穴に入れて
そこで火をつけておけば
それはずっとこの火がずっと仲間でするし
一応炭で物を料理作ったりする場合は
大体穴に入れておくんですよ
で 穴に入れて その上に料理するものやらね
焼くものやら それで焼きますからね
大きい何か物を焼きたければ
大きい穴の中で周りちゃんと炭を入れて
それを燃やすようにして
中にそのものを入れておけば焼いてくれるんですね
それで炎とか何もないんだから
かなり見た目は綺麗なんですよ
例えば人間も手でもほんのちょっと出しただけで火傷をするということでもないんですね
それでも火の温度はかなり強いんです
ですから炎はないんだけど
温度はすごい高い 普通の炎が出る火よりも
ですから高い温度で何か焼きたければ
そういうものを使っちゃいますよと
だから欲も大体そういうもので
一見綺麗に危険がないように見えるんだけど
本当は普通の炎よりは怖いぞと
普通の炎だったらみんな怖がりますけど
だいたい炭の火なんかはあんまり怖がらないんですね
軽々く見ちゃうんですよ
軽々く見ちゃうんだけど
ものすごい温度が高いんです
次のたとえは夢のようであると
夢のようって 夢で食べたごちそうのようにと書いてますしね
夢ですごいごちそうを食べても
別にそれでお腹が満腹になるわけでもないし
目が覚めたら何のこともないんですね
次のたとえ 借り物のようで
借り物 そこでもたとえるのは
例えば何か自分がおしゃれしたくて
とにかくこのテキストではないので
そこの説明は他のいろんなところでいろいろわかりやすく説明しているところがあります
例えば誰かが人がすごいおしゃれをしたくなる
でも自分には何もない
ですから 豊かな金持ちの人にちょっと何か借りてもらう
服とかね いろいろアクセサリーとかね
それを借りてきたら もうかなり大変な豪華な豪華に見える
豊かな人で見える で その人はやっぱり人の集まりに行くんですよ
集まりに行っても胸を張って振る舞うことはできないんですね
全部借りたものだから
やっぱり惨めになっちゃうんですね
だから 貸し手方本人もね
そちらにいるし 人の集まる場所でしょうしね
だからどこかのパーティーなんかに行きたくてね
じゃあ私にも服とアクセサリーとかね
もうもうネクタイやらもうもう全部貸してくれと言ったらね
豪華なものを貸してもらっていっても
その人と一緒に行ってもね
やっぱり なんかね それでもってすごい喜ぶっていうことは全くできないんですね
それからそれだけじゃないんですよ
この借りたものだから
例えば豪華なアクセサリーだったら
ほんのちょっと何かなったらどうしますかね
ちょっと踊っている途中
例えば女性だったらね
イヤリングがそれ落ちたりしますね
どうしますかと 自分にそんな買うお金もともともないでしょうに
大変なことになるんですよ
それでネックレスにしたっても
そんなすごいキツいものでもないし
ちょっと引っ張ったらすぐ破れてしまっちゃうし
ですから みんなでお祭りなんかに行って踊ったりするということはもうできなくなっちゃう
ずっと怖くて怖くて もう心臓がドキドキしていなくちゃいけないんですね
それは自分のものだったら別にもう損しまたとかね
もうもう泣いて叫んだっても
別にもうそんな精神的にということないんだけど
借りたものの場合は大変なんです
だから確かにつけた楽しみはあるんだけど
その分得るデメリットの方が大変多いんだよということで
借り物だと言うんですね
次は木の実のようだっていうのはどういう意味でしょうかね
それはどういうことかというと
この木実はどんな木の実ということでもなくて
いろいろある特殊の木の実
それいっぱいありますよ
で 木の実が出てきて それ全部はじけちゃうんですよ
音を出してはじけて落ちるんで
パチパチとはじけて落ちるんですね
ゴムの木だったら面白いんですよ
もう 2月かな  2月になるともうこれぐらい大きい木の実ですけど
結構大きいんですね それをいっぱいやるんですよ
だからもうずっともうもう 9時
10時ぐらいになって
もう 3時  3時  4時まで
まあうるさいぐらい音なんですね
あっちこっちこのもうものすごい音を出して
爆竹みたいなことを音を出しながら弾けてはじけて落ちるんですよ
木から全部落ちるんです
で 木には何も残りません
大きいんだけど それの 4つがあります
種は これ 4つも別な別な殻で硬い殻で
硬い殻で覆ってます それは全部いっぺんに爆破するんですよ
それであの殻も だから殻は八枚あります
で 殻も開けて 丸い種も落ちて
殻も全部いっぺんに落ちちゃうんですね
まあいつも聞いてると結構もうもうよくまあだからゴムというのは商業用の木だから
もう作場合はたくさんいっぺんにいっぱいもう作ってますからね
だからずっとこの二月終わりまで
まあ森の中に爆竹ているような感じなんです
爆竹作ってるような感じで
そういう音をずっとするんです
だからこのゴムだけではなくて
いろんな種類ありますから
この弾けて落ちるというね
いろいろ種類あります
これは決して珍しいことではないんです
まあ日本の植物は知りませんですけど
日本でもいくつかありますけどね
木の実がまあ音を出して落ちるという
まあ栗も落ちますけど
音は出しませんですけどね
で それもちゃんと弾けて
その全部落ちちゃいます
この皮と一緒に 栗の場合は音は出しません
まあ音があってもなくてもどうでもいいんですけど
木の実っていうのはそんな長持ちするものじゃないんです
あ これは綺麗だとか なんとか
まあもうこれはもう弾けて終わってしまうものなんですね
次にあるのはアシスーヌーパナ
スーヌっていうのはものすごい太いということ
アシっていうのは刀のことなんですね
だからこのすごい太い刀のことなんです
お腹の方がすごい太い
あのこのアラビアとかね
いろんなこの漫画とか見えるでしょうね
すごいこの泥棒持ってる刀とかね
あの日本刀とは違います
いわゆるまあ包丁で見れば
この中華包丁っていうのはすごい太いでしょう
それで刀も同じくこの太いということでね
だいたいあるいはこの剣道で使えるものじゃないんですね
まあ人殺しにしか使えませんね
死刑にする時はそれを使ったりします
ですから 屠殺場のようってこれ屠殺場になったのはどうでしょうかね
難しいなあ  だから屠殺場には別なパーリ語があります
で 人殺す場所にも別な言葉があります
アシスーヌといえば やっぱりあの実生の実は青龍刀なんですね
ものすごくお腹の方が厚く
幅広いバカでかい刀なんですね
それはまあ両手で持って
まあもう人間の首であろうか
まあ動物の首であろうか
まあそれでまあ切っちゃうというね
人間の首はまあ昔もうもう平気でね
まあ切っていたんだから
その場合はまあ刀で切っちゃうんですね
その時使う刀はまあ別の刀
別の刀で 戦争なんかにも使う刀ではないんです
戦争にそんなもの持っていったって戦えないしね
ですから 戦いに使う刀は
まあやっぱり自由に動き回ることできる細いものなんでね
いつでも で それで人の首切ることはできない
刺すことはできますけど
で 刺したり切ったら切れますけど
首なんかきれいにきちんと離れていくっていうことはだいたいありえないんですね
ではそれはもういいんですけど
これはこの楽しみが少なくて苦しみが多いという例えには
まあちょっとまたわかりにくいんですね
まあ恐らくこういうことで
見た目は綺麗でしょうしね
ものすごい鋭くて切れるとかね
で 結局このまあこの肉屋さんとかね
その人々持っている包丁でも結構見た目はいいんですよ
すごい鋭く磨いて もうもうちゃんと手入れしているものだから
普通我々使っている包丁とはものすごい桁違います
で 大きさもかなりあるしね
で見たら ああいいなと思えるほど
こんなにすごい鋭く切れるんだからいいんではないかという
結局まあ首を切ったり
まあそういう仕事に使っているものなんですね
で 次はサッティシルーパマ
サッティシルー サッティそれは槍のことなんですけどね
で 槍といっても これもやっぱり人殺す時使う特別な槍だと思いますけど
それはこの大きいもので
これを地面にきちんとしっかりとこの植えておくんですね
それ植えの槍があって
そこに人を刺して殺しちゃうんですね
手で持って こうやって戦争に使うものではないんです
次はヘビの頭の方と同じだと
まあヘビの怖いところは頭だけですからね
他のところ全然怖くもなんともないんです
ですから このヘビの頭のようなものだと
そのように欲が楽しみで少なく
苦しみの方が多いと
エーワンピコアリットービッコーガッダバーディプットーテーヒビッコーヒサマノユンジーマノーサマヌッガーヒーマノーサマヌッバハスィーマノータデーヴァパー
パカンビッティガタンターマサーパーラマサーアビニヴィッサウーハラティ
比丘たちがそのようないろいろお釈迦様はこういうふうにおっしゃっているんではないか
こういうふうにおっしゃっているんではないか
いわゆる褒めてはないということね
それでも彼が欲はよろしいものだと
ものすごい頑固と もうターマサっていうのはすごい力強く
パラマッサっていうのはしがみついて
アビニヴィッサ その意見のまんまで
その意見の中に入っているんだよと
で そこでこのその経典で何なのかというと
このヘビを例えにしてお釈迦様が教えたある一つの経典なんですね
その経典だと中部経典っていうのは
お釈迦様の一応出来事を書いてますけど
あるポイントに過ぎてお釈迦様が語ったものを記録しているところなんですね
そこでこのカーマということにについてお釈迦様が語ったもの
カーマっていうのは欲なんですね
それでこの欲っていうのはもうまあ 5つありますね
眼耳鼻舌身の喜びだから
色と色声香味触というのは欲なんですけどね
でもこの例えは そういうこの目で美しいものを見たり
耳できれいな音を聞いたりする欲よりも
性的な欲のことを語っているところなんで
この例えが出てくるのは
このそういう異性との関係の場合なんですね
それは比丘たちに出家にはもうもう断固と禁じているんですね
ですから このそれはもうやめられることで
例えばどこかで旅に出たところで
綺麗な山とかね 美しい風景なんか見て
ああ なんと綺麗ですかと思っちゃうと
それも禁じだよと思ったっても
これはちょっと無理なんですね
禁止することが 綺麗な山やら風景見たらもうすごい綺麗という風になってしまっちゃうんですね
それも欲と言えば欲なんですよ
目で楽しみましたからね
でもそれでも地獄に落ちるんだとか
そういうことはあまりないんですね
その場合 お釈迦様おっしゃるのは
ずっと目に気をつけなさい
耳に気をつけなさい 欲が生まれないように修行しなさいとということだから
別にそれで罪を犯したということになりません
あるいはそれはまあどんどんどんどん瞑想すると
まあ楽しいんだけど 欲が生まれないようにいることはできます
突然耳に何か音が入ってきたので
その音をすごい綺麗な音で
あ 綺麗な音だなとと思うことはどうにもならんことなんですね
ですから この眼耳鼻舌身で耳鼻とかね
そういうもので楽しむということが
ここでそれほど激しく言ってるわけじゃないんです
だからこの経典でそこら辺がちょっとわからないんですね
わからないんですけど
そこは仏教は知ってる人はもう何のことなく知っているところで
この例えがリストアップしているのは
いつでも性欲に対してなんですね
いわゆる欲のね 一応いわゆる性欲に対してなんですね
性的な欲っていうのは楽しみがほんの僅かで
それに繋げてついてくる苦しみの方がものすごい巨大なものだよと
ですから メリットよりもデメリットの方が膨大だよと
という話なんですね そこでこのアリッダさんが
これ性的な行為っていうのは
別にそれはなんで邪魔になるんでしょうかと
という意見なんですね
その現代の人々もその意見持ってるんですね
それは体の普通の生理現象ではないかと
それは全然罪とも悪も悪専とも何にもことないではないかと
ふうに論理論するところあるんです
ですから このアリッタさんの考え方は
そんなにいちいち記録している必要はそこら辺にあるんですよ
これはアリッダ坊さんだけの特別な悪しきものでっていうことではなくて
彼が悪いことしたわけでもないんですよ
もし彼が性的な行為を行ったならば
破壊だから それでももう比丘じゃないでしょうね
そうすると経典にはもう記録されません
もう全く外の人だから
だから これはお坊さんたちがそういう真剣にその人に説得させようとしたのは
その人が別に隠れて女性と誰かと一緒にいるわけじゃないんですよ
ちゃんと戒律を守っているんですよ
いるんだけど 自分の哲学としてね
この性行為っていうのは
これは単なるもう体の行為で
それは足が痛くなったらちょっと歩いてみるとかね
お腹が空いたらちょっとご飯食べるとか
ちょっと体がだるいんだったらちょっと背伸びでもしてね
ちょっと気持ちよくなるとか
そんなもので もう体の物質
生理的なことではないかという立場をとっているんですよ
そんなにお釈迦様がものすごいもう激しく反対するんだからね
比丘たちには 比丘たちだけじゃなくて
他宗教の人々にも悪口を言うんだよ
お釈迦様に 他宗教にはお釈迦様に関係ないんだけど
この欲をなくそう欲をなくそうと
特にアージーブカ教の人々も出家するんですよ
アージーブカの場合は
男も女も一緒に出家して一緒に行動するんですね
例えば夫婦で出家したならば
出家しても夫婦は一緒なんですね
そこで そのアージーブカ教では
夫婦でなくてももう仲間が作ったりするし
で グループで行動するんだから
自分に気に入ってる仲間
じゃあ我々一緒にグループで行動しよう
そこの場合は男か女かとはあまり気にしないんですね
ですから どうせじゃあ仲良く修行しましょうと思ったら
どうせ男と女とのセットになっちゃうんですね
だってお互いに助け合ったりするんだから
ぴったし仲間になっちゃうんですね
女性っていうのはいろいろやりたがる仕事もあるし
そういう仕事を男はやりたがらないし
男はやりたがる仕事があって
女性はそれをやりたがらないし
ですから 二人一緒になった方が大体やりやすいんですね
例えば水汲んだりとかね
火を焚いたりする それは男はあまりやりたくない
女性の出家者がやると
でも 建物が壊れた 屋根が壊れたと言っちゃうと
もう森に入って枝を採ってきて
葉っぱを持ってきて 一生懸命苦労しながら住むところを作る
それはもう労働のところ
それは男がすごい気持ちよくやっちゃうんですね
石を運んだりとかね 壁を作ったりとかね
ですから そういうふうなことで
自然に仲間作ろうと思っちゃうと
もう男と女と呼応して仲間になってしまっちゃうんですね
男同士だったらやっぱりどこかで喧嘩になっちゃう
嫌な仕事はお前やれというのは男のやり方だから
ですから そういう場合は二人とも同じ力だったら喧嘩になるんですね
一人が力弱いんだったら言う通りにやりますけど
女性の場合もものすごい互いに嫉妬したり
戦ったり競争したりするんですね
ですから 仲間としては大体そういうことになっちゃうんですよ
それにすると お釈迦様はすごくもう批判するんですね
あのアージーブカの人々が煩悩をなくそうと思って
何やってるんです？なくせませんよと
そんな女と一緒に生活して
決して煩悩ってなくせませんと
かえって余計に煩悩が生まれるだけですよと
サイケでいた時は欲は良くないと思って出家して
出家してから新しい欲が作るんだと
ですから お釈迦様はそういう異性との関係っていうのはすごい激しく批判しているんですね
出家者に対しては だからそのポイントであります
そこでこのアリッダ比丘が
アリッダ坊さんが別に悪いことしたわけじゃなくて
自分の師匠としてそういう思想を持っていたということなんです
その師匠っていうのは人類ずっと持ってるんですね
性的な行為っていうのは徹底した自然のことであると
全くいいものであると思ってはいるんだけど
誰一人も研究はしない
勉強もしない 性的な行為はそんなに完璧な素晴らしいものですかと
世の中一つの目でも開けてみないんですね
両目で見なくてもいいんですけど
この世の中であるほとんどの苦しみがそれから出てくるんですよ
女性殺されるは 男殺されるは
子供は捨てられるは 戦争もするは
病気にもなるわ 家族なんかバラバラになってしまうわ
もうありとあらゆる苦しみがね
時々性欲によってもう一生苦しんだり悩んだり生活する場合もあるし
好きな人は自分の方を向いてくれないということで
一生ショックを受けて苦しんだりする人々もいるし
振られたと思って それで自信まで壊れてしまうということもあるし
それで女性なんかはもう恨みも作ったら
性的なことで それはこの世の中でそれほど恐ろしいことないぐらいなんですよ
男っていうのはそんなに怖くないんですけど
女性の場合はすごい精神的に
それをものすごく効いちゃうんです
だから見方が違うんだからね
男の性的な見方と女の性的な見方っていうのも違いますからね
ですから それで憎しみ恨みを持って一生誰が苦しむかと
その本人なんですよ 時々ちょっと遊ぼうと思って遊んだところで
妊娠したりして で まあどれぐらい苦労するかというとね
中学生やらね 高校生やらね
だからこの世の中ですごい問題多いんですね
あまりにもこの世の中でね
危険多い世界なんですよ
どこかで一人で もうどこでも人をあまりない道路とかね
一人で歩いてみたっても
どこから来て自分を責められるか
殺されるかとわからないでしょうに
別に金を奪うためじゃないんでしょうに
ですから このすごくこの危険
あまりにもありすぎて
楽楽しみということはもうほとんどないんですよ
それなのに平気であれは自然なこと
自然なものやとかね だから
あればこの子供たちがしっかりしなさいということは口先だけで言うんだけど
これは日本の世界を私は見たところで
誰一人も法律やら規則を作らないんですね
子供たちに対してきついものはね
本当はもう自分たちが遊びたいんですね
この年下の未成年の子供たちと
で それで同時にこれはアカンとまた言うし
はっきりしないんですね
どう見たっても これは自然なもの
自然なものっていう感じで
自然なものだったら問題起こるはずがないんですよ
例えば女の子たちが歳ぐらいになってくると
まあおしゃれ好きでおしゃれ好きで
もう随分このまあもう自分の父親も汚いとか追い出したりしたりしてね
それが自然な行為であって
それでもって親子離れたということは一度もないし
で 子供は変に精神的な病気になったっていうことは一度もないし
それが自然な行為で 年頃になってくると
自分の体に対してはものすごい執着し始めちゃうし
男たちも同じ年になってくると
まあやんちゃで何やるかわからない
もう窓は壊すは木登って落ちて骨が折れるわとかね
ありとあらゆることが起きちゃうんですね
だからといって社会問題かと
誰もそれを気にしません
男はなんかいたずらされた
この悪ガキ何やってるんですと怒って
それで終わっちゃうんですね
で お父さんもそれで困ることはないし
お母さんもそれで困ることはないし
ただちょっと叱るだけで叱ったってあんまり気にしないんですね
そんなものは ですから
それが自然なこと 成長の過程で
だから自然なことっていうのはそんなに問題になるものじゃないんで
でも性的な行為っていうのはものすごい問題になるんですよ
動物の世界でも 何でお互いに殺し合いやってますかというと
これ性なんでしょうに
そこで単なるそれだけで
性的な行為って何なのかというと
ただ子孫を作るために我々操られてるだけなんです
我々は奴隷にさせてるんですよ
子孫を作ろう 作りなさいよと
だからちょっと操られてるだけで
そこで子孫を作って 奴隷になって
子孫を育てて 自分たちがもうあんたもう用が済んだと
社会から消えろということなんですよ
だから どんな生命でも
結局そういうことによって
次の世代を作るために奴隷になって働くだけで
その世代がまた次の世代を作るために奴隷になって働くだけで
ですから 性行為の一番基本的なところっていうのは
やっぱり子孫を作ることだけなんですね
だから その場合 でも動物にしたってま
いかに苦しむかというと
一生苦労するでしょうね
タコなんかも見るともう悲しくてたまらないんですね
だってヶ月間かな ずっともう飲まず食わず一か所に留まって
いっぱい卵をもうもうもう何千個ぐらい産んで
それにも水を吹きながらずっといるでしょうに
それで卵 それでも外から魚が来て奪ったりもするし
どんどんどんどん自分が力尽きちゃって
もう卵を守ることさえもできなくなっちゃう
ですから 産んだ卵のもうもう 分の также死ないでしょうし
孵化したっても もうそれで母タコが倒れちゃうでしょうね
倒れた生きたままで 他の魚たちが来てバクバクと食べちゃうんですね
それであのちっちゃな卵から出た子供たちも
また食べられちゃうし
もうだから千個卵を産んだら
大体まあまあせいぜい個ぐらいでしょ
大きくなるのは だからそれぐらい大事な命なんですけど
目的は次の卵を産んで死ぬだけなんですね
他の動物もそれですごい苦労して子育てはしているんですね
ものすごい苦労しているんです
ですから それで何か得られるかって
別に得るものって何もないんです
だからこの子孫を作るという過程自体も美しいものでも何でもないんで
単なるこの奴隷化されているだけ
この DNA に で それはまた社会っていうのはすごく評価する
素晴らしいことだと評価するんだけど
なぜ素晴らしいかっていうことを言ってほしいんですよ
なんでこの知識人だ 知識人だと思う人々が平気で何の理由も言わないで
いきなり素晴らしいと言うんですかと
何か評価するんだったら
それなりの理由が必要なんですね
証拠が必要なんですね
そういうのは何一つもないんです
人間にしたっても 子供作っちゃえば
その苦しみは何年続くかというと
動物の場合は一応一人立ちできたところで忘れちゃえばいいんですけど
人間の場合はもっと続くんですね
その子供に対する苦しみっていうのは
ずっと ですから 一生苦労して子供育てたっても
じゃあその子はものすごいもう人類の王様ですかね
ただのもう一人の人間でしょうに
特別に何の光も輝きもあるわけじゃないでしょうに
ただのもうみんなと同じただのもう一人の人間なんですね
でも そのただのもう一人の人間のために
その生んだ母親と父親がどれぐらい精神的に苦しむかというと
それはいくら年取ったって
親っていうのはもう心配する
自分で何もしてあげることできない状態になったっても
心ではものすごい苦しく
痛み苦しみを感じる 例えば
自分の子供がもう歳ぐらいになったところで
ガンにでもなったとしますね
それで両親の方がまあまあ歳とかね
いったっても一番痛いのは両親の方なんですよ
本人もよりも 年も年でしょうし
我慢もできないでしょうし
ですから そこまで苦しいのはいいんですけど
やっぱり何かみんなこのもう何か結果見て頑張ってるでしょ
例えば ものすごい苦労して勉強勉強するのは何か結果見てでしょうね
みんなもうすごい苦労してスポーツするのはもう何かね
競争でもう勝ったならばそれなりの褒めやらね
ご褒美やらいっぱいもらうんだから
でしょうに なんでオリンピックに出たがるかというと
それぐらいの名誉というかね
それも得られるし すごい財産も得られるでしょうに
それで一生もう食べて生きていられますから
一回だけ金メダルでも取ってしまえば
金でもなくて銅だけでもいいんですよ
銅メダルでも取っちゃっても
それその人はそれで一生もう食べていられるでしょう
だから人間苦労するのは
何かもうご褒美があるならばなんですよ
じゃあこの場合はみんな素晴らしいという
この自然行為の場合 ご褒美って何なのかと
子供のためにものすごい苦労して
苦労して 心配して 痛みを感じて
じゃあ自分が得られるご褒美は何でしょうかね
何一つもないんですよ
ですから そちらにあるのは無意味なからくりだけ
そのからくりにはめられたままでいいのかと
なんでこの自然法則のからくりから脱出しようとしないんですかと
だからちょっと目を開けて見てみれば
無意味で意味がないとこうはっきりわかるもんなんですね
だったらもうちょっと勇気を出して
自分が一人だけでも脱出してみればどうでしょうかということで
だからもう基本的に出家する人々はみんな脱出者なんですよ
出家する時点で 俗世間から
だから当たり前で 性行為はもう禁止であって
そこが基本的なこの連ねの基本なんですね
子孫を作ることが まあそういうことだから
仏教の論理的には これはどうしても認めることはできない
認めちゃうと 仏教はそれで終わりということになっちゃうんですね
仏教の努力も教えも真理も
もう何一つとももう機能しなくなっちゃうんですね
いわゆるブッダの教えそのものを否定したことになるんですよ
単純なことじゃないんです
ブッダを否定して ブッダは認めませんと
否定して何やるんですかね
仏教だ仏教だと言いながら
それほどおかしいことはありえないんでしょうしね
そういうことだから これはブッダを否定することだと
単純に書いてますけど
その裏の考え方はそういう考え方なんですね
だからこの生命の基本というのは
生命は何のために生きてるんでしょうかというと
子孫を作るために生きてるだけなんです
なんで歳 の女の子は一生懸命おしゃれするんですかというと
別に本人がまだまだ相手にもう男は汚いんだ汚いんだと言うんだけど
結局は準備してるんですよ
男を呼ぶための だから歳の女の子のまあ綺麗好きなことっていうのは
もう誰でもやっぱりかなり距離を置いて男たちが座らないと
それぐらいのことなんです
結局はそれからはもう男は逃げるぐらい
まあ逃げたくなるほど
まあやっぱり相手を呼ぶでしょうに
男の人もなんでいごいご喧嘩しながらも体力つけて
また男なりのいろんなおしゃれをしながら頑張ってますかね
結局は相手を呼ぶためなんです
だから 生きる目的っていうのは
単なる子孫を作ることになってるんですね
それである人が子孫を作る
生きる目的は達しましたよと
その人がまた子孫を作って生きる目的を達しました
それだけですかね 生きるっていうことが
だから なんか言ったら
まあ行ったらもう天国に行けるんだからとか
もうどうでもいいような話ばっかしでね
成仏できるんだとかね
だからそんな証拠一つもない話だからね
具体的に見ると ただの子孫を作るための人生
だから女性の美しさも全部終わるでしょうに
子供産んじゃうと 全部子供に吸収されちゃいますからね
あのプロポーションも体の綺麗なこともおしゃれも
なんだかんだもう跡形もなくもう全部壊れちゃいます
全部子供に吸収されちゃいますから
そこでいくらもう頑固でわがままで生きてる男たちであろうとも
子孫できちゃうと 子供のために全部もうそれを差し上げてしまっちゃうでしょう
その子供も同じことをする
その次の子供も同じことをするという
だからそちらには全然智慧の働きはないし
人間の自由意識で行動っていうのはまるっきりないし
誰一人も自由意志で行動しているわけじゃないんです
操られているだけ だからそちらには独立性もないし
自由な思想もないし 自分で考えてるわけじゃないんですよ
考えさせてるんですよ
だって小さい時は男も女ももう男の子たちも女の人が嫌いで嫌いで
小学生一年生二年生の男たちに聞いてみて下さい
もう大嫌いですよ 女っていうのは殴られたり蹴られたりするんだから
いつでも 力ないんですよ
男の子 小さい時はね 女の子には力があるんですよ
体力は でも女の子っていうのは別に自分の性に目覚めてるわけじゃないんだから
女から見れば やっぱり男っていうのはなんかちょっと変に見えちゃうでしょうね
だから蹴ったりしたくなっちゃうんですね
そういうふうにお互いにすごいもう小さい時から憎しみ合ってるんだけど
結局大きくなっちゃうと全く全部逆になっちゃうんですね
親もいらんと だからそれは自由思考じゃないんでしょうね
誰かのことを気に入ってしまえば
それは理屈はありますかね
大体みんな知ってるでしょ
愛には何の理屈もないんだと
何も理屈がないんです
ただ その人のこと好き
それだけ だから その性欲の世界では
もうそれはまあ自然なことなんですけど
結局自由意識がない 独立性もない
何か人間のレベルを乗り越えるということは
もうもう全くできない状態です
ただ操られている状態だけ
だからこの勇気のある人は脱出するということで
そこから仏教始まるんですね
出家した時点から ということで
この性的な行為っていうのは
全くも仏教ではいかなる理由があっても認めることはできないんですね
そういう考え方 裏にあるんですけど
経典と注釈書ではそこら辺ちょっとわからないと思います
それから全部繰り返し文句だから
このストーリーだけで十分だと思います
そこでその比丘たちが一生懸命もう説得させようと思っても
彼が理解しないんですね
彼にとってはこれはあくまでも自然な行為で
ごく普通なことであると
瞑想に邪魔になるわけじゃないんだと
アントラー愛かっていうのはデンジャーということで危険
障害って意味なんですね
お釈迦様が悟りに危険なものに危険と言うんですね
別にこの熊が危険 虎が危険ということは
仏教であまりその言葉使わないんです
危険という言葉を使うのは
悟りに対しては障害 障りになる
危険になるという意味です
ですから 自由を目指す人が徹底的依存を評価するとありえないんですね
依存することこそ素晴らしいことがないんではないかと言いながら
じゃあ私は自由を目指して頑張るぞと
いい加減にすればいいんだ
それだったら そういうことだから
これ成り立たないんですね
それからこの性欲っていうのは
この筋肉の希望であって
だから体 体っていうのは腐って死ぬでしょうに
その腐って死ぬ体のための目的で生きている人には
心を清らかにするっていうことは全く不可能なんです
体を支配している心を管理しようとしてるんだから
やっぱりこの体の面倒見た途端
心の奴隷になっているんですよ
だから いろんなところでいろんな教えで肉体はもうちょっと馬鹿にして置いておくんですね
肉体の整理はほどほどにしなさいと
心の整理をしっかりしなさいと
だから我々は肉体のために力入れるということは
心がどんどん堕落するというふうにセットになっているんです
だから仏教はこの肉体も苦しいものだから
このまあ一つの病 病の塊で見てるんですね
体イコール病気と いわゆる病態というかね
体っていうのはある病の塊であると
それで病だから まあそれなりにも痛いとかね
もう叫んだりするでしょ
体がお腹が痛いぞとかね
喉が渇いたぞとか 足が痛いぞとかね
だるいよとかね その場合はそれだけちょっと
ちょっと何かしてあげればいいんです
それ以上言ってはいけないんだと
だから死なないぐらいは食べると
体維持するぐらいのことを食べると
寒さ 暑さ ちょっと体をね
弱いんだから体を隠して守られるぐらいの服を着ると
ちょっと体異常現象を起こしちゃえば
病気だから まあ即的な意味で
その場合は薬とか何とかちょっとあげちゃうと
じゃあこれ飲めと これ飲んでこの痛いのはもう消して消しなさいよと
それ消したらそれで終わってほしい
でも精力剤やらね 美人になる薬やらね
薄く皮膚がすや性になるものやらね
それは仏教では禁止なんです
それは体の奴隷になってるんだから
それだったら全く心清らかにする世界とはもう離れちゃいますね
まあそういう風にはなってはいるんです
そこでアリッタさんが全然聞いてくれない
それでお釈迦様に報告する
お釈迦様に報告するところは随分長い
パーリテキストでは百三十一ページの終わりまで
百三十一ページの終わりでアタクーバガはアンニャタランビクンアマンテーシ
で お釈迦様がある比丘を呼びます
比丘たちがお釈迦様に報告しますね
我々は頑張りましたけど
なかなかあの人がね あんな悪しき思考は捨てませんよと言われたところで
お釈迦様は他の比丘を呼んで
あんた言って 私があの人を呼びますよということを言いなさいよと
そこでまた同じストーリーを続けるんですね
その比丘がお釈迦様のところに来る
お釈迦様がその比丘に質問するんですよ
あなたはこういうふうな考え方を持っているということは本当ですかと
その人は本当ですよと言うんですね
そこでお釈迦様はこう言うんですよ
カッサコーナアマトワンモーガプリセマヤエワンダンマンデーシタンアジャナーシ
私はそのような教えを誰に教えたものかと
こういうこと お釈迦様が欲は障害になるぞと教えてありましたね
それでこの人が アリッタさんが
まあそうおっしゃっても欲はそんなに障害になるとは思いませんよと
私はそういうふうに理解していますと
納得していますという意見を持ってますね
お釈迦様が 私は誰にそんな話をしたんですかね
もし誰か一人の人に対してでお釈迦様が
なあ 君の場合はまあいいよと
君には障害にならないんだよと
特例でもあったならばね
いいということなんです
欲 性的な行為は悟りには障害だよと言ったんだけど
例えばある人が来て 例えば王様が来て
私は それはちょっと無理ですよと
妃たちがもう百人ぐらいいるいるんだからとかね
言ったならば お釈迦様や王様の場合は特例で
王様は大丈夫やと何かそういうことでも言ったならば
アリッタさんにもケースがあるんですよ
だからアリッタさんが
だってお釈迦様が何とか王様にそんなことをおっしゃったのではないかと
お釈迦様に反論すればいいんですよ
だからお釈迦様は私は誰にそんな話したことがありますかと
ということは 誰にも言ってないってことなんです
アリッタさんに出す証拠ないんですよ
そこでお釈迦様すごい叱るんですよ
お釈迦様はもう気に入らない
もうもう廃人にするんですよ
人々 あんたはもう終わりやと
もう出ていけという そういうゴミ扱いする場合は
人のことも愚か者という言葉を使うんですね
モーガプリサっていうのは
本当に意味は空っぽのモーガンというのは空空ということなんで
いわゆる禅に禅というのは財産なんですよ
佐藤瞑想したり どんどん心清らかになることはものすごいこの上ない財産なんですよ
宝物なんですね だからそういうこの上ない宝物は持ってない人はもうやっぱり空っぽなんですよ
ですから 普通の人間 みんなお釈迦様から見ればみんな愚か者で空っぽの人々なんですね
瞑想でもして 修行でもして
どんどん心を清らかにする人々は
コスコスと財産貯まってるんだから
その人々は愚か者じゃないんですね
ですから 修行する人々には愚か者とは呼ばないんです
修行してどんどん心を清らかにしているならば
決して愚か者だと思わないんです
その時ももう間違ったら怠けたら叱るんだけど
やっぱり激しく もうこの愚か者とは言わないんですね
ですから お釈迦様いきなりもうこの愚か者と言ったら
その人はもう捨てられてもういるんです
お釈迦様はまたお釈迦様も同じことを言うので
私がいろんな言葉でいろんな表現で欲が危険であると言ったんではないかと
また同じ言葉を繰り返していくんですね
最後にこう言うんですよ
私は欲が楽しみが僅かで
苦しみの方が膨大だと言ったんではないかと
アタチェパナトゥアンモーガプリサアッタナドゥッガヒーあなた愚か者が自分で間違って私の教えを理解して
だからこの教えの中身は私はこの経典でなかったんだけど
説明しましたよ この性欲はなんで仏教はそんなにも断固と反対しますかっていうのは
これはものすごい深い思想なんですよ
深い真理なんですね この心の独立
心の自由っていうことはもうありえないんだからね
それと一緒は ですから
もうそれはしょうがないことで
ですから この人が自分でこれを間違って理解したっていうんですね
アンメーチェはアッバーチッカシ私を誹謗しています
ブッダのことをそれだけじゃない
アッターナンチャカネシ自分でも自分の掘ってるんだと
いわゆる自分立ってるところで
自分で大きな穴を掘ってるんですね
アッターナンカネシっていうのは自己を掘ってるんだという
もう破壊 自己破壊になってるんだと
バフンチャアプニャンパサバティあなたはすごい罪を犯しているんだと
だからブッダの言葉を誹謗することは大変な罪なんですよ
それは宗教的な意味ではなくて
心理的な意味で もうとんでもない罪になるんですね
だって人間の頭はもうどうしても咲いてない頭はさらに咲かないようにすることだから
タンヒテーモーガプリサバビスディガラッタンアヒターエドッカーエ愚か者あなたにはこれが長い間苦しみになるんだよと
もしこの考え方を持っていたならば
あなたはものすごい延々と苦しみを味わうことでしょうと言ったんですね
でも もしかするとお釈迦様にさえ
このアリッタの考え方を直すことをできなかったんです
だからお釈迦様はその人はなかったことにしたんです
だから 例えば自分の頭悪くてもいいんですよ
ただの多可性でしょうに
ただの多可性だからね
インド社会の過去の制度から見ても
何のこともない人でしょうね
教育も何も受けてない
もう多可性っていうのはやっぱりいろいろ狩りやらいろんなものに動物使ったことであって
別にもう格が良くないんですよ
そういう人がブッダの世界の仲間一緒に平等で扱われ
受戒させているんだから
お釈迦様っていうのはもうインテリ中インテリで
もう天才中天才で もう王様の人であって
王家の人であり だからもうお釈迦様が言うことは
自分でもう徹底的に理解できなくても
お釈迦様が言う通りにすればいいでしょうに
その場合は自分の身分で
これぐらいのすごい高い位の出家までしているのだから
だからお釈迦様にとってはその人に説得させることはちょっと難しいんですね
これは理解の問題だと思います
この多可性ぐらいの人にとってはこの自然の法則やら
この遺伝の法則やらね
もう生命っていうのは生存することのための奴隷ってそんなわかるわけないでしょうに
だからまあタカにはどんな肉がいいかとかね
どんな音を出せば飛んでくるんでしょうかとかね
どうやって狩りをすることを教えられるかとかね
それぐらいの知恵しかないんだからね
そこでお釈迦様は彼を否定するんですよ
アタクバガはビックーアーマンです
比丘たちを呼ぶんです
タンキンマンニョテビッカビアピナーヤンアリットビックーガッダバーディプッボウスミーカトピイマスミンダンマウィネ
これはなかなか他の経典で出てこない一行なんですよ
これすごい宝物のような言葉なんですよ
お釈迦様が比丘たちを呼ぶんです
そこでアリッタが座っていて
比丘たちに聞くんですよ
あんた方どう思いますかね？この人は仏教に新しい考え方を起こして
いわゆる改変したんですかと
改良したと思いますかと
いわゆる新しい風を吹かせたと思いますかと
ウスミーカタというのは温めたという意味なんですよ
食べ物でも温めたら食べられるでしょうに
だから仏教はちょっと冷えてしまって
ブッダの教えが元気がなくなっちゃって
そこでアリッタが新しい思想を出して
ブッダの教えを温めたんですかと
という意味なんです だから単純な日本訳でアリッタが仏説を温めたと思いますかと
という意味なんです ウスミーカタというのは温めたっていうことですからね
だからお釈迦様がアリッタさんの思考自体をけなしてるんですよ
こんな思考を持ってきて
仏教はなんかわいわいと新しい風が吹いて新しくなると思いますかと
そうしたら比丘たちがみんな否定するんですね
キンヒスヤバンテ ありえないんでしょうと
そんなことはありえないんだと
ノーヘタンバンテ 違いますと
キンヒスヤってのは こんなアリッタさんみたいな他者にはブッダの教えに新しい風吹かすっていうことはね
ありえないんだと そんなことはないんだと
誰も相手にしてないんですね
だからみんなちゃんと理解しているんだから
エワンゴってそのように言われたら
アリットビックーガッダバーディプット
もう彼が負けちゃって
トゥンヒーブーと もうしゃべらなくなっちゃって
マンクブーと もう全部自信もなくなっちゃって
もうすごい恥かけたっていうことですね
パッタクアンド 肩ももう前に落ちてしまって
体も アドホームコー もう下を見て
もう顔も上げられなくなっちゃって
パッジャヤントアッパティバーノーニシーディ
パッジャヤントっていうのはもう何も思い浮かばない
頭真っ白くなっちゃって
アッパティバーノーっていうのはもう何も浮かばなくてっていう状態なんですね
元気も全部なくなっちゃって
もう徹底的に落ち込んでしまっちゃったんですね
そこでお釈迦様がアリッタさんがね
もう全く何もできない状態になってね
落ち込んでしまったことを見て
アリッタにそう言うんですよ
パンニャーイッサシッコーとはモーガプリセエテーヌサケーナパーパケーナディッティガテーナ
あなたは自分で旗を立てて
自分の考え方でね パンニャーイッセっていうのは自分の名前を挙げてみんなに知られてもらうっていうことなんですね
あんたは自分の思考で頑張ってくださいと
旗をあげてくださいと
その悪の思考でね この邪見で
私はこの意見だと どうぞ自由にやってくださいと
イダハン・ビクク・パティポッチッサム
私はこれから比丘たちに質問して説法する
彼はもう全部もう廃業
もう関係ないということで
どうぞ自分勝手にその思考で頑張ってくださいと
あるいはもっと親切な
この動詞はどんな動詞でか
パンニャーセッタの動詞はね
どんな解釈でいいかわかりませんだけど
動詞の種類いっぱいありますから似てます
種類は 逆にこのことであなたはみんなに知られてしまいますよという優しい言葉にも解釈できます
こんな悪意見であなたのことはずっと知られてしまいますよ
だって今までアリッタの名前残ってるんだからね
そういう意味だったらすごい親切な言葉になりますけどね
でも現在形でこれ解釈しちゃうと
あなたは一人勝手に頑張ってくださいということになります
注釈書ははっきりとこうやって訳するんですね
アリッタさんが一応お釈迦様に断られたんだけど
これからお釈迦様が私にいろいろ説法して
なんとか悟られるようにしてくれるだろうとかね
期待したでしょうと 自分がもう落ち込んでしまったところでお釈迦様が助けてくれるだろうと
でもお釈迦様は助けてくれなかったと
その場合は パンニャーセット
このあなたはこんな悪い意見を持っていくならば
あなたは地獄に落ちたり苦しんだりするんでしょう
だから勝手にして下さいっていう意味になるんでしょうと
私はママサンティカトイハン・スグトーワード・ナーマ・ナティ
私はあなたにはこれからは指導しませんと
私にはあなたとはもう何の関係もないんだと
ですから これから比丘たちに喋りますよと
責任ないんだと 言ったことを聞かなかったんだからね
断るとやっぱりそういうことになってしまうんです
まあだからこの まあどんな訳でもいいんですけど
分かりやすいところは
アリッタさんの考え方を変えることはブッダにできなかったっていうことなんですね
で それでアリッタがもうみんなに断られちゃって
誰も味方がいない そうするとものすごくもう落ち込んでしまったんですね
それだけのことで で お釈迦様も比丘たちも誰一人味方がいない
全く自分一人だけなんで
お釈迦様はどこにも微かにでも欲を褒めたことはないんだから
もう何の頼りもない 在家の人々と一緒に
じゃあ我々は意見 それでもできない
在家の人々にお釈迦様は同じことを言ってるんだからね
彼はとにかく切り捨てることは確かなんです
ここら辺で今日は終了します
それからお釈迦様の説法になります
何か いきなり今日初めて参加なさってる方々は
何言ってるかさっぱりわからなかったところあったならば
どうぞ遠慮しないで聞いてください
今日はこのパーリ語で読んだんですけど
これはお釈迦様の経典で一番古いね
お釈迦様が語った言葉なんですね
だから今日我々が持ってきたのは
世界である一番古い経典なんですね
日本にある仏典とは随分違うんですよ
これ元々の教えなんですね
だからお釈迦様生きてた時代に実際にあった出来事と
実際にお釈迦様が語った言葉と
その仏教の内容なんです
ですから この普通我々の耳に入っている
勉強している 日本語で読んでいる経典というものとはすごい違うと思いますけどね
だからこれは歴史的にちゃんと喋った本当の事実の話なんですね
だからそれたくさん経典
全部ほとんど全部残ってますから
全部と言ってもかなりね
それはパーリ聖典と呼ぶんですね
こちらでこのお釈迦様のその元々のパーリ聖典を勉強しているところで
これを今日やりましたけどね
で 残り半分も勉強してみると意味がわかると思います
何をおっしゃっているかというと
一応このお釈迦様おっしゃる場合は
この全て一言葉でまとめて喋るんでもなくて
いろんなこの問題ができて
その問題を中心にして説法するんですね
これはちょっとしたエピソードで
あるお坊さんが在家の人々と同じく
異性と関係を持ったってもどうったことないんではないかと
戒律で比丘たちに出家者には異性との関係はもう厳密に禁止しているんです
それでそのお坊さんがそんなに厳しく禁止しなくても
ごく普通なことではないかと
という意見を出しただけなんですよ
それについて仏教 またお釈迦様はそれから説法する
今日は説法のところには行かなかったんですね
時間なくなって この前の説明がもうしっかりしておかないと
大体それくらいわかると
なんとなく脈絡は頭に残ると思いますけどね